all right we're gonna kick things off
with all the big DC news so luckily
tomorrow here is our resident DC expert
time what with a big takeaways from the
sea air show there was a lot so they had
a DC / more number of his panel and like
I said there was a lot in there so I'm
gonna channel the Speed Force to get
through this quickly the first thing
that they showed was the debut trailer
for Wonder Woman which was excellent I
know if you guys saw it I'm assuming you
didn't yeah what did you think of it the
action scenes looks like there was
intense as Batman V Superman but didn't
have Superman in it so they were good
anyone oh no I really like the look of
it um cuz i thought when i was watching
batman vs superman wonder woman was one
of the redeeming qualities of that movie
and I was excited to see what they would
do and I thought gal Godot was a grey
Wonder Woman so I'm really excited also
to get Chris Pine Chris Pine get him at
the enterprise different different
franchise yeah i really liked and what I
noticed was it kind of what what made
her memorable as a character in Batman V
Superman was also kind of what made the
trailer for Wonder Woman quite memorable
the badass Wonder Woman like she did a
lot of punching dudes and she did it
really well she'd like a no scope 420 in
the air I went with a bow and arrow and
I was like COD player definitely and
like they were still look like a heart
to it as well like you know she met
chris pine's character and their
relationship is going to be a key part
of their you know the movie going
forward humor color it was like the
first trailer that kind of like denoted
a shift in kind of tone and style for
the DC movies very you know moving away
from the darkness from the bit kind of
po-faced ya know well the one is still
pretty dark yeah but into like the
Marvel you know stuff's going on it's
all really bad but you're gonna have a
little quip here and there yeah I like
the last line where she helped the
secretary be a little more woke what is
a secretary I go where he tells me to go
when I do what u tells me to do more
around from that's called slavery I
really like her fantastic ladies are you
into I did mine so more of that kind of
shift in tone we got to see in the
Justice League trailer so finally the
squad is together no shouldn't call him
the squad cuz that mean legally elected
decent league is being put together
man is continuing his efforts to you
know assemble the greatest superhero
group in December universe I keep see
but I didn't like other like franchises
into this as the Guardians Oh God yeah
so what did you think of that trailer I
as a huge fan of the Justice League it
made me very very happy to see these
characters come together and the dynamic
seems to be one with familiar with the
kind of reminded me of the one eyed
reading comics or even like in the
animated series you get like carefree
but also kind of a bit vulnerable flash
you get you know Batman and you know
Wonder Woman's dynamic it seems it's a
little lighter it's not like the one
they had with you know between Batman
and Superman in the movie which was just
the can we talk a little bit about
Aquaman yes my days I think because
everyone's made so much fun of him they
are they throwing it that much further
into the other end like even made fun of
for years make him the most badass thing
about the whole trailer so bad as he was
unbelievable I thought I thought flash
as well clearly the comedic chops of the
squad League klase squad Suicide Squad
but that was one unlike and again it's
like doing the Marvel thing quick quick
quip yeah every 10 seconds or so well I
don't I don't think it's gonna be as
much like marvelous because Marvel they
build legs like a lot more around comedy
I think this is going to be like the
little personality shining through an
Aquaman seems to me he you know he's
always he's always his issue is that he
has to balance his kind of allegiance
from responsibility to the land above
versus you know his own Kingdom and I
think that's key to what his angst is
about I think if there's going to be any
angst in the movie it's going to be
mainly focused around him and which I am
okay we've also him standing from the
wave while it's just like crashing into
him was a bit much well I think I didn't
like though is how in the trailer
everyone kind of got their little
introduction and some some bands and
cyborgs just like I'm here and I'm and
Cyborg was there too yeah I just hope
that doesn't reflect on how his
characters gonna be the movie like yes I
bought some some China yeah he's key to
that the league in terms of getting
stuff done like he can open portals and
he's basically the information guy but
he's also very very important to like
the pa's a powerhouse so I hope they
give them equal amount for
tension the next one we got see was a
suicide squad which is out in a couple
weeks I am continuing to like be
surprised at how much I'm excited about
it seems like the first I think they're
trying to position it as the big movie
that you know the kind of really really
pivots on what DC and wanted movies are
going to be like so we had Batman V
Superman and people are like man this is
a bit boring and it's a bit to me thanks
T a bit I'm a bit of an apologist for
for those movies but I think this is the
start of them saying like we can do fun
movies to look at all the color we've
got the soda libelous kids yeah check
out our rick ross song but yeah you guys
can I know a lot of people that are like
I'm done now with DC I'm full Marvel are
you guys being drawn back into i very
much am being drawn back into it by The
Suicide Squad yeah for sure I wanted
something there's a bit more fun
especially after like the biggest thing
was the dark knight previously bit of a
palate cleanser in the way of suicides
got to be good and add some really good
music in that trailer and twenty one
pilots yeah I will see Suicide Squad I'm
not like jumping up and down to see it I
think it has a potential to be good and
I hope it is good at the point I'm at
the point now where I've just been so
oversaturated by the marketing I'm just
like oh it's another Suicide Squad
trailer like it's a character trailer a
character trail another trailer I'm just
like I done now just what I'd see it
okay I'm I'd rather take the hairs a
character here's a character like
constantly seeing pictures of characters
then them really digging into like this
is the story because I hate your own
trailers do that especially for
superheroes the movies because
traditionally they're not overly complex
so like you know just keep it brief just
show me characters move on I'm around
that so coming out of comic con how do
we think DC's looking I think they're
looking a lot better than they did
before and after Batman vs Superman and
all the other Superman movies I think it
shows that someone there is listening
and understands you know what they need
to do to change and someone there's also
looking at Marvel and being like BAE
they seem to have this nail down maybe
we should borrow it I think someone's
raining in zack snyder as well and being
like you aren't as good as you think you
are relax
and getting some other people Henry
shoots and giving more money for that
stuff is it's encouraging I'm more
encouraging now than I have been before
yeah I'm on board of that like you like
you said it's that they're taking
lessons from Marvel they realized that
the dark gritty stuff isn't going to
last forever that people are going to
get bored of that and I imagine that's
probably half the reason why i suah
squad got the green light they were like
okay let's let's at least try something
silly something fun something you know a
bit wild so hopefully if that pays off
we'll see more cool different stuff from
DC because they've they've got they've
got the back catalogue of interesting
characters I hope they have some of my
favorite yeah they've just never been
brave enough to explore them so
hopefully now they will be Booster Gold
movie don't really good eyes
you